this is where landscape architect
Claudia nguoi Meister works in the 300
year old Moscow castle gardens in
tottenham I'm cloudy annoy Meister I've
lived and worked in Moscow park since
2009 and today I'd like to show you
three of my favorite places here it's
largely thanks to Claudia that
pineapples are being cultivated here
again that carries on an old princely
tradition starting in the 16th century
it became fashionable among European
nobility to grow the exotic tropical
fruit in their own aura sharees loft was
picked up in koukla who valued prestige
and making an impression discovered them
for himself and grew them here in his
greenhouse Claudia and her friend yan
Grunfeld like to go biking a popular
activity for tourists here
the town of bud Moscow lies on the
popular odor nicest cycle route which
runs along the German border with Poland
but Moscow is surrounded by the park
about 4,000 people lived in the small
spa town
hidden in an old building is a
passageway that locals have known for
generations but hardly a tourist has
heard of until now yeah here we are at
the alley that leads to the old church
ruins will follow it to the uber vague
pathway Moscow residents used to take
this shortcut uphill to the church which
dates from the 14th century it's now a
ruin but well worth a visit isn't it
we've now arrived at my first
recommendation one of several wonderful
observation points along the moscow uber
vague here with the romantic church
ruins in the background wonders and Kurt
Hawking them hint ugh one you can really
enjoy the view from one of these stone
benches come on this
the last service in the church took
place in 1785 nowadays Moscow residents
celebrate a traditional New Year's Eve
Mass in the ruins
we continue on to what was once the
Bobby Nicole Mayan lignite or brown coal
was mined here until nineteen seventy
three
a geological trail gives you a closer
look at the unique aspects of the
countryside
you find out how it was formed by the
last ice age and altered by mining that
explains the rust colored water in some
of the lakes a result of mining visit
yet we're now at my second
recommendation this lovely observation
tower we're going to climb up and take a
look at the scenery from above
the thirty meter tall tower in the Geo
park was built in 2014 it gives you a
panoramic view of the landscape known as
the Moscow arch
now we head back to Moscow park after
the 15 kilometer tour it's time for
refreshment and the oleander restaurant
the salon only under restaurant is my
third recommendation because you can sit
out in the open air on the edge of the
park in a relaxed atmosphere atmosphere
though this is this happened I think
we've earned it the restaurant serves a
sweet specialty homemade first propeller
ice cream a 19th century cook at the
Prussian royal court named his creation
after the prince who was so important
about Moscow Claudia nguoi my sister and
her friend enjoy the fine dessert and if
you travel to Bob Moscow you can try it
yourself